I'm compressed today we're on the quest
for the scariest game ever made I asked
Bruce on Twitter what's the scariest
game ever we're gonna find that out
today Bruce are you prepared good
I can see you're not wearing any pants
first game was recommended by twitter
user as monk oh really yes and it's
called what the [ __ ]
turn up the volume Bruce listen y'all
god this is actually [ __ ] creepy
hello oh my god I give up
set your [ __ ] oh my god
I need to collect 8 pages I get it
it's another slender clone could this be
the scariest game ever we're about to
find out where the [ __ ] are all the
pages how am I supposed to find any
pages oh god I'm actually terrified what
the [ __ ] my god flashlight don't leave
me no pages what am i doing out here I
don't know what's going on but a delay
key net when big the only thing scary
about this game is the [ __ ] graphics
at least it has better grass and grass
simulator Jennifer what are you doin
here defect you shut that gate your turn
its pitch bad what the [ __ ]
Oh barrels barrels what do you do in
there barrows
Oh tractor give me the note
no longer finish no you ran out of time
and suffocated all right that was Slendy
pants an old classic next game is cold
one after another it's me on the toilet
it's probably one of those Japanese
toilets let's go we don't need to poop
forever this is kind of creepy what the
[ __ ]
hello what can hide that's never a good
thing
why am i naked I need to find pants ah
[ __ ] what this [ __ ] was out see that's
why you need paints oh my god let's go
this way
well [ __ ] me I can't go that way all
right just be careful for trap speeds we
can hide in that oh it's Prasad gently
John rotted oh god what's that [ __ ]
sound let's go upstairs yes oh god no
I'm hiding I'm ready I'm ready
aah fight you piece of [ __ ] uh-oh
hey I'm free hey that's going guys watch
out for traps
all right let's [ __ ] watch out for
traps let's go upstairs hello how's
everyone doing this is great don't like
the sound
I don't like a plants how you doing like
you I like you a lot I don't remember
how the tribes looked like they look
deadly oh no it's a dead yeah
oh god it's one of those [ __ ] hey
girl you like my pants ah she doesn't
like them she doesn't like my pants god
damn it I knew they were too tight
all right we're fine we're fine oh [ __ ]
chicken walkout set dah dah dah
ah [ __ ] she [ __ ] punch me in the deck
I need a place to hide I need a place go
[ __ ] ah don't molest me god dammit
oh my god this game is hard man all
right we need to find a way out and get
ourself a proper pair of pants - [ __ ] me
we need to get out and find a proper
pair of panties pants pants
I said pants I said pack what is love
baby oh I saw that trap it's ah damn it
so the goal is not to just go upstairs
ah buddy faked that ah I'm just going up
and down I'm such an idiot
oh my god [ __ ] knots minecraft man
alright go down I'm hiding
don't add me I'm fine ah [ __ ]
checked my eyes out don't that's gross
ah
great game that was one after another
I started this series ironically because
I thought I wouldn't get scared at all
forgot I'm a little [ __ ] damn it keep
forgetting that detail alright next game
was for mekin hey yellow holy jesus
christ as lone hmm alright so let's see
here
good poopin hello hello what that [ __ ]
am i doing okay that was terrifying
next up we have sonic cantide nope
don't care what the [ __ ] you bros link
me I'm not touching that [ __ ] I don't
want to see your dick please oh it's a
five nights at Freddy's clone did we
really did we really need this I think
this is based around a creepypasta
I think I heard about this it's like an
abandoned Disney theme park
am i right I guess I'll just sit here on
my lil desk I'll buy no Mickey my
favorite Mickey when it Mickey go ah
oh where did make it go Maykel you there
you [ __ ] [ __ ] thank you
now don't say that oh yes Mickey
impression ever haha I heard something
Jose what was say what was that I don't
know what I heard it it sounded like
someone just came oh that's how it
sounds like when he comes oh boy oh boy
I don't I don't know what I'm doing okay
this is so boring
nothing is happening
nothing is happening really I don't want
to play another night that was so boring
Donald Donald hug me oh all right I'm
done thank you
this game contains this terribly Emma
June the graphic all right close your
eyes burrows project frequency this game
is in pre-alpha alfalfa pretty this
looks actually pretty cool
how do I come on there we go all right
Bram
ah ah ah [ __ ] those nipples are nasty
this Oh hot it melts I can use it as a
football this is great hey how's it
going you're coming with me nipple man
this TV is making me feel uncomfortable
it feels like someone is trying to get
inside my head
well I'm trying to get inside that ads
if you know what I mean I'm sorry
I'm so sorry hey no way I see something
I [ __ ] see something oh my god I
can't run very fast but I can jump like
a boss ah
faster faster sanic fest
right jump hop base aah stop please
please have a lighter what it's the
hormone hey how's everyone doing I can
actually run this time great as a mellow
alright oh [ __ ] me a text a mammal might
set sound
did you just fart ambulance god dammit
not in front of me oh god it smells and
blames stay away spot of shotgun stay oh
my god oh god ah [ __ ] me Lisa Lisa I
will not date you [ __ ] get it right
oh god you crazy [ __ ] stop hammer time
yeah damn Lisa and her crazy girlfriends
hey family I say what the actual [ __ ] is
this oh my god what the [ __ ] is that
kill it this is what happens when you
watch too much weird Japanese porn
alright
that's what happens oh god they're
coming ah [ __ ]
a baton but ah it's baton I put some
missed you up miss you too
now let's [ __ ] some [ __ ] up but ah but
ah that's [ __ ] right suck my ass
Empire hey you dropped some apples
little [ __ ] why don't you pick them up
haha [ __ ] what Elliot come from no I
will not kiss you you dirty [ __ ]
oh god you dirty stop stop
[Music]
haha oh my god
ah that's stop it's not bad I guess
alright now the last game suggested by
jazz jpg what the [ __ ] it's called Joe
Jonas dress-up game
[Music]
God God no no no no no ten attend my
favorite game which game was scariest
vote in the description like you enjoyed
this video hit subscribe to become a bro
today and as always thank you for
watching stay awesome and we're up what
the actual [ __ ] is happening
[Music]
Kevin hey why ride the horse when you
can fly that horse